what's the difference between a geek and
a nerd a geek is a person that has
functional utility and intellectualism
so you can think about a coder someone
like elon musk for example they actually
provide a product that people can use
tesla for example there's a bit of
intellectualism involved because there's
some coding there's some numbers there's
some math and that's what a geek is now
a nerd is a person that has
intellectualism but lacks functional
utility you can think about a person
that studies 18th century poetry or like
14th century russian literature or
something it has no impact upon society
at large the average person doesn't
benefit from it but there is that level
of intellectual rigor and a dork has
neither it's not to say that you can be
just one or the other you can fit in all
categories i mean there's certain things
that i like that are entirely nerdy
would you assume that most people who do
some sort of science or geeks yeah a lot
of my friends are in the humanities and
i refer to them as nerds and they say
that oh you're not a nerd you do math
all day i'm like yeah i'm a geek i'm not
saying that i'm better than you guys i'm
just saying that there's a my new
difference between what you do and what
i do mine is useful and you're a nerd
yeah exactly i solve crap that's you
that's hilarious